قبل ان نبدا بتذكر قصتك الاسطوريه العظيمه
اولا ما رايك في استخدام كلمه فتاه النقال
مش صغيره التي تمسكت بك وبحياتك على طول
[موسيقى]
حسنا كنت في التاسعه من العمر والحرب
اقتحمت حياتي وانعم اصبحت ضحيه او اصبحت
رمزا لمفهوم الضحيه ويطلق عليه
تلك الصوره اول مره لم تعجبني استغربت
لماذا التقطت ذلك الشخص الصوره على هذه
الشاكله كانت هيئتي فيها غير مرتبه باكيه
وعاريه وكنت طفله صغيره لقد شعرت بالعار
لم تعجبني تلك الصوره بالمره لكن لاحقا
بعد فتره علمت ان تلك الصوره اصبح تتمتع
بقوه رهيبه في الاعلام والراي العام
الدوليين واقنعتني لاحقا وكارس جهود من
اجل السلام لا سيما عندما اصبحت اما هنا
في كندا وعندما انظر لصوره اشعر بانها مثل
النداء لي لحمايه طفل العالم من شرور
الحروب لقد حملتني تلك الصوره مسؤوليه
الدعوه لحب الاطفال وحمايتهم وعليه ان
احدث الفارق في هذا العالم بالدعوه الى
الحب وتجنب المعاناه مثل ما تعرضت لذلك في
الماضي لذلك فانني ارى ان تلك الصوره
منحتني حريه الاختيار بين ان ابقى سجينه
الالم او ان اعمل على تغيير العالم بما
استطيع من موقعي ولذلك كان اول ما فعلته
هو انني قبلت تلك الصور